Їй було лише 4 роки, коли її визволили з Варшавського гетто.
Йоанна Соболевська-Пиз завдячує цим польським підпільникам.
Але історію свого порятунку вона дізналася набагато пізніше.
"Ось це я."
Перше фото її дитинства - зроблене після звільнення.
Батьки-євреї організували її втечу з гетто.
Вона цього вже не пригадує.
"Мого батька звали Грюншпан , а мою маму Зільбербарт."
"А як  ви дізналися про вашу історію?"
"Свою родину я розшукала в Ізраїлі. Написала до
однієї ізраїльської газети і з'ясувала прізвища.
Так я знайшла свого дядька."
За день до повстання маленьку Йоанну передали
активістці польського підпілля,
яка мешкала в цьому районі Варшави.
Жінка знайшла для дитини прийомних батьків,
ті похрестили її як католичку.
Лише у 18 років Йоанна дізналась про те, що вона єврейка.
Дівчина тоді почала розслідувати власну історію.
Першою, до кого вона звернулася, була її польська рятівниця.
"Вона мені сказала: ти мусиш бути вдячною Соболевським,
що вони тебе виховали і що ти змогла вивчитися.
Вона наголошувала на ролі Соболевських.
Однак я хотіла знати якомога більше про своїх біологічних батьків."
Завдання не з легких. Адже після повстання 1943 року
майже всіх євреїв, що залишились там, німці депортували до концтабору.
Майже всіх їх згодом вбили.
Про гетто й 300 тисяч його жертв нагадує пам‘ятник
на тому місці, де стояв сумнозвісний пішохідний міст.
Він з'єднував великий та маленький квартали,
куди німецькі окупанти запроторили мешканців-євреїв.
Нікому не можна було без дозволу залишати цю територію.
І все ж польські борці з нацизмом врятували
єврейських дітей, попри мури та наглядачів.
У Музеї історії польських євреїв , що у Варшаві,
досліджено, в тому числі, й історію цих дітей.
Серед них і Кристини Будницької.
Вона була в гетто, коли почалося повстання 1943-го,
і сьогодні є одним з останніх свідків тих подій.
"Де був бункер, у якому ви сховалися, Кристино?"
"Це було на розі вулиць Заменгофа та Міла.
Мені було важко дізнатися щось більше.
Я намагалася з'ясувати, хто саме з, так би мовити,
"арійського боку" допоміг мені.
Але й досі не знаю, яка ж група повстанців мене врятувала.
Єврейська організація "Зегота" чи "Єврейський комітет"?
Досі не знаю."
Будницькій було 11 років.
Старші члени родини сховали її у спеціально
збудованому бункері під будинком.
На той час двох її братів уже депортували із гетто
до концтабору "Треблінка" і там убили.
Коли почалося повстання, вона сховалася ще глибше – у каналізацію.
Німецькі окупанти жорстоко придушували збройне повстання євреїв.
Жінці вдалося уникнути загибелі разом із трьома іншими людьми.
А потім їх знайшли і врятували поляки - учасники спротиву.
"Нас витягли із каналізаційних стоків та посадили у мішкИ."
"Чому в мішки?"
Ми вже не були схожими на людей.
Ми були скелетами і ні що не годилися.
Після дев'яти місяців під землею, без світла,
без контакту із зовнішнім світом.
До кінця війни вона переховувалася.
А потім потрапила до сирітського притулку.
Сьогодні Кристина Будницька розповідає молодим людям
про свою долю, застерігаючи щодо праворадикальних настроїв.
"Коли така велика група людей у Варшави
передасть спогади свідків іншим, тоді, я гадаю,
в антисемітизму немає жодних шансів.
Це у ваших руках – хай щастить! Я вам дякую!"
Кристина та Йоанна заснували спілку "Діти Голокосту".
Вони хочуть, аби їхні історії почули.
Про життя і смерть у Варшавському гетто.
Доки їм вистачатиме для цього сил.